I remember for avengers
The Russo brothers are like so here you're standing here, and you're fighting this guy and just do whatever. I'm like "okay?"
"Who am I fighting?" like well, we can't tell you because it's a secret
Okay, so what does he look like and like well we can't tell you because it'll give it away
I'm okay, so what does he how big is he you know well?
we can't tell you because that would give it away so I'm just standing there punching the air for 15 minutes and
When I took the job I didn't think that's what I would be doing but uh, but you know I've got used to it now
When you're ready
why don't you try that on?
And I'll introduce to the world the newest official member of the Avengers spider-man
Hey everybody
So I've been getting a lot of requests to do a video for iron spider costume during
Infinity war like actual comic book iron spider not just the iron spider of the MCU that we've been calling his suit so far, like the stark tech suit
both of them are stark tech
But the infinity war suit is like legit stark tech because it looks like metal Ironman armor
Which is very close to comic book iron spider, but if you're finding me for the first time there is an Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
That's going on right now
All you have to do to enter it just be a subscriber and leave a comment on the video
So even if you haven't been combing the internet day or night looking for what special functions this suit has that are
upgrades from the previous version of the costume obviously
I think we can assume that it still has suit lady like Karen probably gets
Transplanted into it because even though it started out like more of a comedy thing, having Jennifer Connelly the wife of
Jarvis in real life the person who used to be Tony Stark's AI is just too fun in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
It's like a fun Easter Egg, but it's also really nice, too
She has a really nice voice if he goes back to the cloth suit for the second homecoming movie after Avengers 4
I think that suit lady will jump into each version of the suit
It'll be like Iron Man and Friday for the last several movies
He's had the same AI even though he's had several different versions of the costume
But I think the question everyone's really asking is will it actually have the iron spider
arms because people have been looking at the Lego sets and trying to use those as
Benchmarks for what they might and might not do just remember that Lego sets aren't always 100 accurate
They give you an idea for things
But there were a whole bunch of thor ragnarok
Toys for Sakaar that had absolutely nothing to do with the stuff that we actually saw in the movie
But that being said yeah hundred percent
I definitely think that he has the iron spider arms from the actual comic book version of the costume
even though the MCU version looks a
little more classic colors
I think they did that from a branding reason like they want him to feel like classic spider-man
while at the same time doing all the coolest stuff from the comics that they could possibly do in the actual iron spider comic
book costume
Looks more like an Iron Man costume the burnt orange and gold just don't feel like a spider-man costume and because this is gonna be
the biggest movie on the planet this next year they want you to see
Spider-man and think spider-man they don't want you to think spider-man in an Iron Man costume you see what looks like the serrated plates
It's possible that this is kind of like the briefcase Iron Man suit that forms around him a little bit
Obviously it's a very lightweight version of an Iron Man costume
My initial guess is is there's a piece that it forms out of it probably sits on his back because that would be the most
Spider-man thing ever to have your costume form around you from something on your back
And if they're gonna do the comic book arms from the iron spider suit the arms would come out of his back, too
So you'd have to have a little piece that those could come out from
But if you look at how big he is and how thin the suit is I'm guessing that whatever
Arms he would manifest they're mostly used for stabilization like you don't know how?
Dexterous they could be he would actually have to tell suit lady what he wanted to use them for like suit lady grab on to
That with the arms or there would have to be some sort of automatic function
But I don't think they've taken it so far that he has neurological control
And they work like extensions of his own body like he can't just think grab onto that with those arms
there's not enough time to explain him learning how to use those there'd have to be some kind of crazy montage and
Typically the way that they surprise you with new technology is like with the suit lady surprise during homecoming
There's a ton of other sub systems in here
but they're all disabled by the training wheels protocol
What? Training wheels protocol?
Good evening Peter hello
Hello congratulations on completing the rigorous training wheels protocol in gaining access to your suits full capabilities. Oh, thank you
So where would you like to take me tonight?
I put a tracker on someone
you didn't know that there was an AI in the suit
Until they hacked into it and turned off the training wheels protocol
And then he just put the suit on and it automatically turned on like Oh surprise
There's actually an artificial
Intelligence in here the spider-man timeline of the movie just sounds like it's him having a normal day in Queens on his way to school
Just thinking about the next cool adventure that he wants to have with Tony Stark
And the Avengers when his spidey sense goes off the charts
He sees the ship over
Manhattan makes a beeline for that and then at some point they're gonna have to explain how he gets this new version of this suit
Because obviously there's a lot that happens between him being on the bus and him jumping onto this ship
So I'm guessing that everybody makes a beeline for the sanctum sanctorum because you see Tony Stark there with everyone else
spider-man probably meets up with them and Tony is
Responsible for having the suit come to them like he would have to tell one of his drones to bring the suit
Otherwise it wouldn't really make sense like at the end of homecoming the whole deal was is he's like
I'm not ready for that. I just want to be the friendly neighborhood spider-man
He gives him back the normal version of the costume, and that's the end of it
He's just gonna continue using that while he learns to be all the spider-man that he can be
So it really does sound like spider-man is gonna be a big part of that
sanctum battle like obviously
there's all the ebony maw stuff the time gem because that's what they're really coming to the sanctum for so I'm guessing there's just a
Whole bunch of stuff in the trailers that we have not seen yet
So I wouldn't be surprised if when he's jumping onto this ship here
And he stands up the arms actually fold out and it's this big hero shot
It's just that they haven't added it to the trailer because that requires a lot of extra CG and it's kind of a spoiler
So it's probably a Thor Ragnarok
Situation where they cut the trailer and they just omit a couple of things just to leave you in
Wonder like I wonder what this is gonna be like but let me know in the comments
Do you actually think that when he's slowly standing up here in this ultra hero pose?
This is like the most trailer shot moment ever
That his arms pop out of his back because look at all this negative space like normally in a frame you would have all
This other stuff behind him
But this is just dead space
Waiting for something to fill it and what better to fill it than eight badass spider arms
It just feels like a really easy slam dunk
holy crap
Moment that people will be talking about after the movie like you remember when he jumped onto the ship and his iron spider arms came
Out and he didn't realize that he had those
But that also makes you wonder too here when Thanos
Grabs him after he jumps at him in midair and slams into the ground if they'll also add
Iron spider arms all crumpled behind him
But there was a scene at the Comic Con footage that hasn't made it as a trailer yet where he's doing that Civil War thing
Where he's like, I'm sorry mr.
Stark and iron man starts freaking out because he's so worried
Don't you wonder if when he's crying into this hand here if he's actually holding Peters hand
I know there are a lot of theories about Pepper Potts wearing the Iron Man armor during this Thanos battle
But simplest explanation is is it's just a bunch of Avengers get their asses handed to them
And he's just really upset so it's possible that someone has died in this scene, but like I said
There's a new round of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway. I'll announce the winner from this video the next time
I post Marvel, but congratulations to the winner from the last video, Sergio, Mercado
Please private message me so I can get your contact details click here to watch that
Avengers infinity war panel where they talk about x-men and Wolverine crossover and click here for brand new black panther
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight